moonfall is a movie about the moon
collapsing onto earth and that's the
simple part we haven't even gotten to
the swarm of ai robots yet
[Music]
[Applause]
it's on airplane mode
moonfall begins when a routine space
mission goes awry with two astronauts
brian harper and joe fowler barely
surviving what brian can only describe
as an attack from an unidentified source
joe having been unconscious assumes the
assault was some kind of solar flare the
disagreement leaves the colleagues and
friends estranged with brian becoming a
washed-up deadbeat to his only son sunny
while joe moves up the nasa ladder ten
years later a conspiracy theorist named
kc discovers that the moon has been
knocked off its orbital path and is on a
collision course with earth he winds up
teaming up with the two former friends
to figure out how to correct the moon's
course but they both balk at his theory
that the moon isn't what it seems they
begin to grow more sympathetic to his
crackpot theories when joe is promoted
to head of nasa and given clearance to
see the original footage from her and
brian's botched mission there she meets
a mysterious spook named holdenfield who
explains he's been responsible for
covering up the truth about the moon
since earth's earliest expeditions joe
starts to come around to the craziness
when she witnesses with her own eyes the
phenomenon that brian tried to get her
to believe a heart-stopping swarm of
black nano machines
she surmises that whatever this entity
is its presence is what set the moon out
of alignment if earth is to be saved it
needs to be dealt with but even though
nasa's top brass have been aware of the
moon not being what it seemed for
decades they don't know its true nature
all they know is that whatever it is
it's more advanced than humanity can
handle
initially in response to the moon threat
joe had scrambled an emergency mission
with the help of some european allies
the intent of the mission was to see
what's inside the 26 kilometer deep
crater on the moon that the black swarm
had come out of but that mission killed
everyone involved so plan b has to be a
little more drastic
with no faith or support from the rest
of the government and very little
resources at their disposal joe has to
bring in brian who encountered the
entity before and kc whose status as a
megastructurist might prove useful
especially now that she knows most of
the accepted knowledge surrounding the
moon is completely useless the new plan
is to get a lander onto the moon's
surface equipped with a super powerful
emp the military had been developing for
years to deal with nasa's secret moon
problem the project had been abandoned
as too costly but one working prototype
still exists which is what ends up being
used in an attempt to destroy the black
swarm as the moon's gravitational pull
and exponential velocity increases the
plane starts to look impossible to pull
off the one usable rocket loses one of
its engines the moon itself begins to
fall apart as it gets closer to earth's
atmosphere sending debris all across the
landscape but the gravity tsunami that
the moon brings with it proves to be
useful in getting a rocket out of orbit
even without the engine thrust necessary
to get the rocket to properly launch
unfortunately this scientific revelation
comes after everyone working for nasa
has been released to go home and find
shelter with their loved ones leaving
the films three leads to embark on this
insane mission alone
with the original plan b already looking
like a failure the military-industrial
complex gets hard at work on a much more
logical solution to this absurd problem
they're going to nuke the moon this adds
extra pressure onto joe and brian's
mission as they're stranded out in space
unsure of whether their cowboy maneuvers
will even work and if they do they have
no way to communicate with the military
to stop them from nuking the moon to
smithereens but joe does have one
contact on the inside as her ex-husband
doug is with the joint chiefs in the
colorado doomsday bunker joe was
supposed to bring their son to compared
to joe and brian doug is a
straightforward guy who isn't exactly
thrilled at the nuke the moon plan but
in the absence of better more concrete
plans sees it as humanity's only chance
to keep from having the moon hitting
everyone's eyes like a big pizza pie if
only he had some way to know that his
ex-wife's long-shot plan of getting a
rocket into space actually worked
luckily brian's son sunny alongside joe
and doug's young son saw the rocket take
off they've been driving to the doomsday
bunker themselves running into all
manner of apparel but joe's son has a
satellite phone with a direct line to
his dad so they're able to notify doug
that the mission is active if he pulls
the trigger on launching all those nukes
he'll be pulling the trigger on dooming
his son to grow up without a mother this
leads to a standoff between doug and
every other authority figure in the
bunker right at the moment they're meant
to begin the launch sequence to initiate
to nuclear onslaught on the moon it's a
crazy bit of drama because doug doesn't
understand joe's plan how it's going or
if it's even feasible all he knows is
that joe has never let him down before
but the plan is essentially screwed
ryan's initial idea is to lure the black
swarm out by exploiting its reaction to
electricity before destroying it with
the emp but it sees through their ruse
when it tries to destroy the ship they
realize it's not solely electricity that
the swarm responds to but rather organic
matter alongside machinery with no other
recourse brian pilots the lander into
the deep crater the swarm is retreated
into and that's where the real fun
begins
you know we are just inside the moon
that might be the greatest sentence
anyone's ever said
the inside of the moon is as casey had
theorized a megastructure an enormous
vessel crafted by advanced alien life he
says some in his community believe that
all megastructures are arcs but what
they discover next proves he's only half
right as the swarm tries to destroy them
there is another opposing force within
the moon's core one that takes over the
controls of the ship and guides them to
safety on the other side of a blast door
an area they discover that has air when
casey and joe wake from the crash they
discover brian is missing and go
exploring this newfound space
but brian is already communing with an
entity that possesses all the answers it
speaks to him in the guise of his son
but it's the operating system for the
super machine that is the moon it's a
mega structure but it wasn't created by
aliens it was made by humans as told to
brian the moon is an art created by a
form of the human race that was far more
advanced than ourselves they had created
a utopian society and proliferated
throughout the cosmos but one day the
artificial intelligence they had created
to help run this society grew sentient
turned on them and vowed to destroy all
of humanity they created moons to find
suitable places to build new planets to
be seated with human life our earth is
only one successful settlement created
from the moon and seated with human dna
the moon orbits the earth to protect it
should the ai swarm ever find it as it
has now
the operating system tries to understand
why brian is so willing to risk his life
to save the rest of the planet and his
answer about love for his own son and
for his race lets the moon know he's
ready to get back into the game and stop
the ai it supercharges their ship gives
brian what can only be described as
temporary superpowers and sets him out
to get into a dogfight at the moon's
core with a malevolent swarm of human
hating nano machines the ensuing laser
battle culminates in the realization
that one of them is going to have to
stay behind in the lander to detonate
the emp and put a stop to the swarm for
good ryan has decided to sacrifice
himself but someone else has other plans
casey a man who has spent his whole life
having his scientific beliefs treated
like a joke who no i never thought would
amount to anything has finally gotten to
see space and see his research and
life's work validated casey has in the
last few days of the film's narrative
lived more of an exciting life than he
previously had in all his prior years
combined that's why he can't let brian
or joe stay behind when they have
children on earth that need them ryan
must go back now as the main conduit to
the moon's deep reservoir of knowledge
regarding humanity's secret history
casey is going to stay behind and
culminate the unlikely journey he
embarked upon at the film's introduction
he sacrifices himself defeating the
swarm and making it possible for brian
and joe to reunite with their families
on earth his sacrifice doesn't seem to
be permanent as the film closes casey
re-materializes in the same space brian
learned about the moon's true origins
only now the operating system presents
itself as casey's mother and his cat
fuzz aldrin it explains that his
consciousness has been uploaded into the
moon's supercomputer and that his work
is far from over
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you